welcome to kill test
that sucks
it's bad
the Gian sword first appeared in China
all the way back in the 7th Century BC
wisely designed the sharp lethal tip was
ideal for Rapid cuts and stabs while the
wide body aided in deflecting attacks
considered an elite weapon due to the
amount of training needed to master the
sword the straight double-edged blade
was built for subtle instant strikes
requiring a level of precision in
finesse that only comes from a true
swordsman because it was so difficult to
master the Xian was removed in Mass from
the battlefield however many are still
involved in ceremonies and featured in
films including Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon
all right blade space welcome to kill
test
now your Gian swords look beautiful but
are they deadly well to find that out I
will take your weapon and do some
slashes and thrust on this ballistic
dummy
Ben's here first you ready Gabriel
okay
all right fans let's talk about your
Gian sword up here overall
I like the Aesthetics of this sword now
your handle construction is within scale
of this blade it's comfortable when I
wrap around it
now your Edge
is razor sharp in thrusting it cuts out
and when you swing you can feel the
impact of this sword overall sir
it'll kill wanted to hear that good job
hey Casey you got the stomach for this
you're next I'm ready
[Music]
all right Casey let's talk about your
Gian sword here first up I like the
lines that you have with your sword here
and the Damascus pattern I can
appreciate that
and now in cutting it was so much fun
just to be able to slice over and over
and over
with ease with the blade that moves
this sir
will kill thank you
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
now to test the edge holding ability of
your blades and the overall strength and
construction I'm going to take each of
your swords and smash them repeatedly
into these heavy pots now I'm not really
concerned what your blades do to the
pots even though it's going to look
really cool and be a lot of fun I want
to see what the pots are going to your
blades and edges
Vince you're up first you ready to go
yes sir
foreign
is still Sharp
still straight and true
but the problem is
doing your pommel
your threads here didn't go very far
through so Pummel broke loose
a bit of a problem
Vince your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure after three shots
on the pots a Pummel is critical to a
one-handed weapon's retention but that
doesn't mean that this competition is
over Casey
these are some pretty strong terracotta
pots and you'll have to survive Three
Pot shots to make it out of here I feel
ready all right Jay you ready
if the pots can knock off a pommel they
could do anything it all comes down to
this got a little bit of knots in my
stomach let's see what happens
looks good
Casey congratulations your blade
survived Vince unfortunately you cannot
continue testing please exit the forged
I'm disappointed I think I made a hell
of a blade it was still sharp after the
three terracottas
but the blade needs to be a hundred
percent
mine was 98 percent
and he failed Casey congratulations you
are the force and fire champion and
that's the title that comes with a check
for for 10 000 big ones buddy
congratulations
great steel and a great job on the
handle too
proven to myself that I can make a damn
good blade for me that's nothing better
the sword of gujien
foreign
is an exquisitely crafted GN sword
wielded by King guccian ruler of China's
Kingdom of you after brutal battles
between the you and the Wu King guccian
was forced into slavery in exchange for
sparing his people after three years of
servitude King guccian rebuilt his
Empire conquered the dwindling Kingdom
of Wu and was bestowed this sword
featuring a sharp lethal tip intricate
blue crystal and turquoise guard the
sword was just as ornate as it was
deadly more than 2500 years later the
sword was discovered by archaeologists
in a remarkable condition still with a
razor sharp edge it has been called one
of the most intact artifacts ever found
blade Smiths welcome to the kill test
[Music]
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do according to start
design I will take your weapon deliver
some killing thrust and blows on this
ballistics dummy for us are you up for
this yes sir let's do this
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about your weapon here and
it's very forward heavy what makes it
hard to handle is the fact that you have
a very skinny handle right here a lot of
these movements your blade went up on
contact was spinning in my hand
I had to adjust several times to make
sure that I stay on the edge over here
now the edge is sharp once it makes
contact and you slash it digs deep while
we're all sir build a Kill
all right Caleb you're up you ready
let's see it
[Applause]
all right Caleb first up the blade in
itself balance wise
think you nailed it now your handle
construction it's avoid it's actively
comfortable because of the balance and a
very sharp edge all the cuts are very
very deep overall sir
it'll heal
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
a Gong chop
tends to strength and durability of your
edges as well as the overall
construction of your swords of gujian
I'm going to be chopping them into these
gongs of course you're up first you
ready yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well Forrest your sort of did take some
damage on the edge there's some rolls
sort of crushed in right here your
handle is really small a bigger handle
would help me control this really well
but all that being said that much damage
and a big strength does like this
well done
thank you
all right Caleb you're up you ready heck
yeah man
well Caleb he did a great job with the
Damascus I love to see this kind of
stuff it's beautiful your blade is still
a straight true
and the weight on this is phenomenal
there is one big issue though
your handle
it's loose now
your handle is coming apart I can move
it and their pommel is also loose if
these were right and tight and held in
place then it tends to help everything
else stay where it is but just a little
bit of play in this guard can send shock
waves right down the handle but uh gotta
say that's one heck of a blade thanks
Justin thank you you know this handle
that's really causing the issue now yes
sir
so we've got a pretty mobile opening
that has a corresponding split on the
back side of the handle not only is it
loose but the material that's loose has
sharp edges okay now I mean this would
require either Taping that up or wearing
a glove and now we're not testing the
same as the other one okay Ben that's a
gorgeous sword
the handle's gone the tape kills me uh
yeah okay
foreign
with blades that had loose Parts before
we've continued with blaze that had
split handles before your
handle has cracked
however the combination of the two
things has made or played unsafe to
continue with any testing and therefore
you cannot be our forged and fire
Champion I'd like to invite you to shake
our hands shake your competitor's hand
and then I have to ask you to please
leave a forge
I may not be the forge and fire Champion
but a man I'm walking down here with my
head held high and I'm proud
[Music]
Forrest congratulations you are the
forge and fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars my friend good job I'm
on Ford I'm thrilled that I'm the
Champion hasn't even soaked in yet and
next day or two I'll really realize
what's happened being a fortune fire
Champion means I succeeded in the goal
that I wanted to reach
this is for everyone at home and I'm
coming home with forged and fire
Champion yeehaw
foreign
originating in the 1500s the Jumanji
Yari was carried by Japanese soldiers
known as the ashigaru these peasant foot
soldiers relied on the long-shafted
spear for its reach and versatility in
combat using the weapon's double-edged
crossbars to disarm and pull mounted
samurai from their horses ashigaru could
then employ the razor-sharp central
blade to fatally skewer the Fallen enemy
and all from a comfortable distance
today video game enthusiasts can unleash
the Jumanji yari's devastating
capabilities in the game shadow fight 2.
the Yari with its long handle and
multi-pronged spear makes it a trifecta
of points and edges in a deadly weapon
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I will take your Yari and
deliver multiple slash and thrust on his
picarcus blood you're up first you ready
oh I'm ready
foreign
Jesus
alright for what let's talk about your
yachty here we felt that it had very
good balance to it that on the initial
slash right here it dug in into flesh
then it hit the spine the transference
of energy hit a weak spot into your
handle over here but it still had a
secondary cut all the way through I
would consider your blade a Kill
thank you it was man man was
beautiful well-made
and some wood grain just you know
who I your weapons suffered a
catastrophic failure now that's bad
however you're not out of this
competition yet Jacob your Yari still
must perform in this kill test let's see
what happens right now I'm feeling
nauseous
Hearts behind my chest my hands are
sweaty and I'm
just can't wait to see how it actually
goes down
all right Jacob let's talk about your
yachty in the initial swing instead of
being able to cut cleanly with this part
to cut through this got in the way with
the angle that it had but let's talk
about these particular blades they are
sharp enough to penetrate into the pig
carcass the thrust is really devastating
and very deep into that your handle
Construction
it stayed true no issues at all overall
your weapon will kill thank you sir
my Yari held up and I'm just thank you
cupboard
the blades of your Yari were beautifully
constructed the overall weapon was very
elegant however your shaft broke in our
first test and we cannot move forward in
this competition because that is a
catastrophic weapon failure
and I have to ask you to please leave
the forge I was really confident going
into the competition and I felt like my
Yari was going to really perform a lot
better than Jacobs and it's just pure
irony all the way down
Jacob you are the forged and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
you feel right now so amazing I can I
can prove that I can actually come out
here at 19 and compete with serious
knife makers thank you sir really I
would have liked to beat fuad in a
different way but I'm a fortune fire
Champion ten thousand dollars
it's awesome
foreign
Rising the popularity in the 1600s the
Spanish navaja was a deadly folding
weapon common in duels and street brawls
this blade could be folded into the
handle and locked in place making it
easy to conceal it featured a locking
ratchet mechanism which kept the blade
in place
the ratchet sound of a navaja opening
was also used to intimidate foes wielded
with the blade up but straight from the
navaja was difficult to Parry and wounds
were often fatal the bajas were often
inscribed with pithy phrases in Spanish
boasting about the deadliness of the
blade the Spanish navaja an iconic
folding weapon from history it's even
said to influence the American buoy
knife to see what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do wall ticker Spanish
then deliver killing blows on this deer
carcass
Matthew you're up first you ready oh
yeah
okay Matthew nice and solid work right
here but I'm still recovering from an
injury so please welcome Anthony Palmer
Anthony is one of the chief instructors
of mercaida Kali today he will have the
pleasure of wielding your Spanish
my biggest concern going into testing is
the sharpness of my blade
your blade is beautiful and it's also
solid in its feel it lacerates easily
you can see it shop right through the
spine now one of the pieces here came
flying out during the test
but in terms of the sharpness and the
wieldability of your blade it will kill
oh yeah okay wait it's your turn you
ready you bet
this way I can hear the mechanism
working in there
foreign
the third of that deer carcass hitting
the floor is absolutely the sound of ten
thousand dollars I feel like I'm ahead
that's where I want to be I want to win
it
all right Wade your blade is sharp thank
you the one issue is it's kind of
rickety here even while it was being
wielded but despite being rickety it's
deadly and it will kill
here next up is a strength test then
test the strength and durability of your
Edge as well as the overall construction
I'm going to smash into this bamboo with
your Spanish navajas Matthew you're up
first are you ready oh yeah
[Music]
well Matthew this thing's wine a hell of
a chopper held together beautifully
there was slight glinting that happened
up here near the tip but it's pretty
darn Sharp
very well done thank you
Wade you're up next you ready
yeah I'm ahead he's ahead all right my
head he's ahead we've been this way the
whole time it's a battle I want to win
it
now it's broken
oh Wade we have a problem
on about the third strike things started
to get kind of loose and that torquing
and the stress made your scales pop off
the only thing holding the cutting end
to the handle end are these thin brass
sheets and I don't have confidence in
their strength this blade has lost its
structural Integrity it's no longer safe
to test
weighed due to the catastrophic failure
of the structural Integrity of your
weapon we cannot continue testing that
blade so I have to ask you to please
leave the forge
I thought I could be down the door with
that thing but you know apparently you
can
Matthew congratulations you are the
force and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job
I just spawned forest and fire and I am
so excited being here as a winner means
a lot to me I've had so much support
throughout my life to do what I am
passionate about and my passion has
proven to be what I should be doing I'm
supposed to be a metal worker stay with
it don't stop keep going
foreign
spirit
the Messiah lion spear gets its name
from an East African tribe of fearsome
Warrior Nomads that date their Origins
back to the 15th century traditionally
used to hunt lions the weapon features a
double-edged blade at one end and a
fearsome Spike at the other this allows
a messiah Warrior to engage his opponent
in close quarters or at a distance
while today lion hunts have been
replaced the deadly spear lives on in
popular culture and can even be spotted
in the film Laura Croft Tomb Raider the
Cradle of life to see how lethal your
weapon is I will take your Spear and
deliver lethal blows on this big carcass
Matt you're up first are you ready as
I'll ever be let's do this
what I'm most worried about is lateral
force on this spear because it's a very
thin Sleek spear
good
well that sucks
Matt I'm not gonna sugarcoat it this is
bad your weapon has suffered a
catastrophic failure and cannot continue
with testing however John we can't just
declare you the forged and fire Champion
your blade has to hold up for at least a
stab and a slash on this carcass Doug
[Music]
I don't know what to say I don't know
what to think I've never been more you
know nervous in my life
I'm hoping and praying that it doesn't
break in the same spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
s to the Limit John your blade survived
the two cuts on our carcass
Matt that means unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut and I have to ask
you to please leave the forge
I'm happy for it
I'm disappointed given what I know now I
would have gone back and really tried
chopping some things very hard with the
spirit hopefully broken the handle
myself I'm really happy for John maybe
I'm not happy to lose to John but I'm
glad John Won
John congratulations you built a weapon
that held up in our test that makes you
our new forged and fire champion who
also receives a check for 10 grand
how do you feel right now I feel like a
million bucks but I guess 10 grand will
do all right well come on over here and
Shake our hands good job but thank you
very good I'm gonna have to uh talk to
my wife about what I'm allowed to do
with this prize money I know one thing
my baby girl's gonna get in a little new
wardrobe
[Music]